hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to wrestle jump with Wayde
hey guys we blew our brains out with it
with no vibes only way we won't get
found even worse we bleep bleep in your
life no no no but it was yes yes yes it
was very yes yes yes we we're like going
into this so tired originally but this
day has been so bizarre they kind of
like we've been building this up cuz
he's been here for a week and we're like
oh god it's like midnight but we got to
do it so we're gonna do it so here we
are and we're gonna play you touch me I
know are you alright yeah are you ready
to wrestle jump as ready as I will be oh
okay
go wait yeah easy I was worried about
the wind in the oh oh yo remember how to
play oh it's a bunch of baloney
oh haha I choked I call that the Mexican
that was stupid you're stupid probably
the way you know oh my god oh come on
and you were so better getting that's
true oh so they're not enough advil in
the work brand add buti'm world Oh No oh
did I mention we flippin y'all I would
flip you on did you mention it wait a
minute we you know haha with the
homeless Emma
and then they slant please no
nom-nom-nom if I forget - yeah let's go
again
hey you can say stuff too I love you
hopefully you always forget to censor
anything on you don't know that what
you're on you keep winning
no hey will you bring what up what's
going over you better thank you oh boy
was he good for you
not the air was not good for you it was
not strike we ended up with a really
good position
ah I hate this case does one know I'm
the greatest
I was I was hustling you don't worry I
was hustling you so well you who sang so
good oh oh yeah oh yeah oh hey do I have
all the power
yeah
okay so anyway the babies were oil baby
oil baby oil previous Brazilian me all
say God also I got all four girls I need
to cover my mouth who's gonna be editing
this for daddy I didn't say anything bad
I just said about me and wait about how
we were plowing each other's buttholes
over and over ain't no that's fine
that's the only that uncensored and
that's totally fine okay but just leave
that the all be places for all the being
alright whatever
all the means no no ah this one maybe
not all the beans maybe some ah
Oh God hey what's going on Oh
ah ring around the mortgage blue Rickon
Frick yeah you get you [ __ ] I'm gonna
give me wall not rare yeah
or to take this game oh oh oh beans in
my mouth
I need to jump over there all the beans
in my mouth all the beans imam al all
the beans in face all the beds all be
really not that bad if you think about
it you've done terrible things to those
oh yeah it's a long night
I'm trying to make one of you
see that's what happens